[Music]
thank you
foreign
Sierras in California here with Brett
who many of you will be really happy to
finally meet because you've emailed or
DM me asking for his contact information
he builds up Vance professionally and he
built mine just over four years ago like
I kind of hinted at in the last video
there are some major changes happening
with my van right now it's currently
under construction so we are taking
Brett's van which he also built by
himself up to Lake Tahoe for a break
from building I've also been living in
this van while he's working on
rebuilding my van which has been super
cool of him and it's given me a chance
to try on my dream of owning a 4x4
Sprinter van which has been pretty fun
but also in this video we're going to
test out the new insta 360 X3 and the
invisible dive case who's also the
sponsor of this video if you saw my
recent videos you'll remember I was just
out here not too long ago and the one
thing I really wish I had with me was an
underwater camera now that we have one
we're heading out on the paddle board to
test it out both as an underwater camera
and also just has an everyday vlogging
camera it's been pretty toasty lately so
I'm actually pretty stoked to dip into
some colder water and in my experience
like Tahoe is freezing so yeah I'm I'm
excited right now we'll see how I feel
when I get out there
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
if you're new to the insta360 camera
system guess what I am too but I can
honestly say after using it for the past
week this is now a permanent part of my
workflow so a very quick rundown of the
i360x3 as a standalone camera this Ultra
compact camera shoots 360 video and 5.7
K and 4K in single lens mode the camera
offers Flow State stabilization and 360
Horizon lock with the option to reframe
your content in post-production using
either your phone or your usual video
editing software on your computer it's
also waterproof up to 33 feet without a
case translation it records incredibly
smooth footage at a high resolution that
allows you to basically choose whatever
composition you prefer in the post
editing process but here is my favorite
feature the invisible selfie stick when
you film with the stick attached the
footage automatically edits it out so
that you can't even see it the X3 also
features some new and upgraded modes to
include 72 megapixel photos 4K lens 360
active HDR me mode AK time lapse 4K 120
photos per second bullet time and loop
recording I'm going to skip details on
these different modes because there are
already some fantastic videos out there
that show just what this camera can do
but what I really want to show you all
is this new invisible dive case with
this case the invisible selfie stick has
the same effect as it does on land and
it disappears in your edit for
incredible third person perspectives and
With the Flow State stabilization and
360 Horizon lock the footage should be
stable no matter how rough the waves get
but you might be wondering why do we
even need this case if a camera is
already waterproof up to 33 feet and the
reason is that without a case underwater
light refraction affects the normal
stitching of 360 footage water has a
higher refractive index than air which
makes objects appear bigger and closer
underwater as you can see from this
footage the old dive case wasn't fully
invisible and it created a problem when
you wanted to reframe a case like the
invisible dive case corrects for this
refraction allowing you to capture
seamless 360 degree footage underwater
and then choose the best angles
afterward when editing so after filming
with this case there are a few things
I've learned that I want to share with
you all before you take this underwater
my first piece of advice is to update
your camera to the latest firmware so
that you can utilize the new dive case
settings next you'll want to put your
camera into dive mode this is how you
mount the camera into the dive case and
you'll want to use these little round
inserts and this tightening wrench that
comes with the die kit to get a really
secure connection this is really
important because if a case moves around
at all the stick will show in the
footage you also have these anti-flog
strips and this wipe to keep the Dome
Clean and Clear which will definitely
come in handy once you're in the water
it's easiest to keep the dive case
closed and utilize these side buttons
here to record and adjust your settings
when you're filming you want to be sure
the case is directly in line with the
selfie stick in order to keep the stick
itself invisible you can see in this
footage that I had the case slightly
bent and so there was a small black
handle visible at the base this might
seem a little unnatural first in fact
for me I filmed a bunch of footage with
the camera tilted toward me like this
because I was skeptical about it
actually getting me in frame but I
quickly learned that the stick and
Camera need to be completely lined and
as straight as possible for the best
results finally last piece of advice use
this lens cap and this soft case
whenever you're not using either one to
protect the lens and this Dome from any
scratches or damage when it comes to
reviewing and editing footage there are
a couple ways you can do this one is to
wirelessly import your files into the
insta360 app on your phone and edit
there the software is really easy to use
and this is what I'd probably recommend
if you want to do a quick edit for
social media you can also import the
files directly into your computer and
edit using insta360 Studio to apply
effects like aquavision 2.0 color
correction or refine a specific
stitching mode and then apply keyframes
in either the same program or whatever
third-party editing platform you usually
use I currently edit in Premiere Pro so
I went ahead and applied a few effects
and insta360 Studio then imported those
360 files directly into my Premiere Pro
timeline so that I could easily edit all
my footage from various cameras together
into one sequence I'm really excited to
continue experimenting with this it
would have been the ultimate setup for
back when I was living in Hawaii so I
don't know maybe I should head back
there sometime soon and try it out in
the ocean I'd actually be really curious
to hear where and how you might use this
camera yourselves or if you have any
recommendations on locations where this
would be really fun to film in if you
decide to pick one up for yourself click
the link in the description below to get
a free extra battery with your purchase
of the X3 invisible dive kit if you
purchase using my link you help support
this Channel and to keep the adventures
going so thank you to all of you and
also to insta360 for sponsoring this
video also let me know in the comments
below if you want to see a little more
of this than well mine is still under
construction and as always thank you so
much for being here I will see you all
in the next one
ciao
[Music]